3 j s also has some built in support for object rotation. The call is like this,
you can specify x y or z for the axis of rotation. The object will rotate around
it's center along that axis in a counter clock wise fashion. The angle is
specified in radians which computers like, as a human I like degrees. So here
I'm specifying 70 degrees then converting this number to radians by multiplying
by PI over 180. Here we can see the direction is counterclockwise if you were to
point the x axis toward you. A way to remember this direction is the right-hand
rule. Even though it looks clockwise in this figure, if you put your thumb along
the x axis and rotate around you'll see it's indeed following the right-hand
rule.